[Music]
wait a second somebody just told me and
virginia you might need to find this for
me for later on
bobby lee broke up with his girlfriend
today on their show
with kai i'm on aila kahlula
ukulele what is that real that's what
i'm hearing
um
yeah hey virgie let me know if there's
validity the rumors of indiana chat me
up on this uh
bobby lee would go on to dump his [ __ ]
girlfriend live on the air
i'm trying to see i'm trying to see what
we find here last hour
i maybe that would be all right
okay i got it i got it do you want to
just do it now let's do it all right
this is [ __ ] right this is breaking i
got it i got it here it is here it is
here it is thank you bobby lee clips i
guess that's the thing that exists you
beat me by a second who made it what
bobby lee bobby lee clips huh
look every you know what i realize
everybody has we have a dumb clip
channel too i think one of my favorite
things about the clip by the way clip
channel about to hit 14k
we're [ __ ] flying up and it's just it
was just it's a backup and clip channel
but it's funny because there's been a
lot of people that are commenting like
oh 14 000 subscribers you got alex jones
i'm like first off it's our clip channel
and secondly [ __ ] you yeah
um before
um
we do our best so yeah this is against
breaking we haven't seen this i guess
we'll find out just want to announce to
everybody that kalila and i are no
longer together
[Laughter]
so why would you do this on air honestly
also how would you keep doing a show
with somebody honestly well she probably
just might be one more
okay
you know this might be it then it's
she's going to be all trash tuesday i
mean i don't know look
does that mean that all of this was for
nothing
everything that happened to the in the
brendan verse everything that happened
everything that happened
was for nothing
absolutely nothing
you know what everything was meaningless
i'm i'm turning a corner right now
i'm now a fan of kalila
i hate i can't she's so annoying she
came in i get it she burned everything
to the ground you're right and then
walked away i with you there but
listen to her no she's awful but
this is this is
she seems really upset about it yeah
let's see who's the one that looks sad
who's the one that cheated
come on
bro seriously
here i go here we go i'm gonna help you
out bobby lee clips this is free
um
it's been not over it's not over i mean
in the sense that
you know
we
i want to say that kalila is
the love of my life
my best friend
um
if there was a book about my life she
would be
i love that i love that chapter the love
of my life she's my best friend okay i
feel like if she's the love of your life
and your best friend right
then i mean staying together is the move
right why'd you break up
i love when couples do this they break
up and they go look
still love her okay i'll always love her
she'll always be my best friend on this
planet you're like
do i break it up though you should just
stay together if you guys are best
friends like that sorry that i've
knocked the thing yeah sorry can i make
a quick prediction
just scoot over just a little bit um
at some point your homegirl is going to
say you know bobby lee is a really great
guy
okay oh let's do that this is great
let's play that okay bob because
remember we haven't seen this it
happened like right before okay so
she's still gonna be coming around bobby
lee's are okay that's a good one she's
still gonna be coming around virginia
remember these or type them or whatever
because i really want to see how many we
hit okay
um bobby lee
says
oh there's gonna be something up maybe
maybe maybe it's meant for later on in
our lives maybe in the future you know
one of those
um also probably i'm i'm also still
extremely grateful to be vaccinated and
boosted oh and i'm she's gonna say i'm
look and bobby's going to look she's
going to stay on the show she's a part
of the show we're not getting rid of her
but in reality she'll be on for another
month and then there'll be someone else
and she'll have a fez roll right exactly
give me that and that's not fair
feather's occasionally funny
how long before how long do you think
after this came out that i did brendon
texture
during it was like throw something off
dude though oh right there if you you
couldn't hear because it's
uh that's why they broke up because she
was texting brenton
that's right it's a good point yeah
um
she changed my life in so many different
ways oh yeah she sure did
she changed it all right
she
reinvented who i was
you're literally the same person you
have always been that i've always known
you to be i haven't seen you change even
in
one iota
yeah and um it's not like [ __ ]
jeffrey ross who went from wearing tuxes
and stuff to now he [ __ ] dresses like
he's in a bts or something
right
yeah
um
and the reason why we're announcing that
i said bts because he's an asian guy and
i can't help but thinking of like an any
asian music you know
the tempura boys is frozen
that is because um there are things that
people
believe online
that aren't true
okay fair
and i want to address those things
because um here we go it's causing a lot
of pain in our house um
home and i'm going to start with
my partner
i'm sorry it's been for years i said
that house isn't a home race it hasn't
been for years no and first off it's
probably a condo so
that's
in our condo and my part is this
you know years ago kalila um
had this heart condition
okay
and and it started in the philippines
we're all part we're all heart
conditions started is that a part of the
heart i wish frozen was here because he
let me know if heart conditions start in
the philippines it's right next to the
left atrium frozen if you're listening
in show links please let me know is that
is that where they start
sir you got a major blockage to your
philippines
i'll have to do something about this
and your korean arteries bad too
seriously
we were in the philippines and i had to
carry her into a taxi and we thought she
was going to die
and um
you know
after that you know at home
we just would have the ambulance
at our house two or three times a week
we'd always constantly go to the
hospital what does this have to do with
you breaking up i'm gonna skip ahead a
little bit
well because i can't be with a [ __ ]
with a bum heart
distinctly remember there were moments
where we would sit down and she would be
crying going what happened with us
here it is there's no intimacy um i feel
like you don't know me anymore i want
you to get to know me again
this is all gay la talk that is thank
you
that is you know what kla talk is
everyone in l.a talks like a woman
that's how women it's all about feelings
and my truth
i want you to get to know me again what
does that even mean
and a lot of times i would do false
promises like trust me i'm just going
through wow she beat him this she's
breaking up with him money on that
but she beat him up so bad that he is
taking all odds
not off air like normal people she's
dumping him and he's falling on the
sword this is crazy
phase or i'm working on it or whatever
and i would um
you know
basically
shrug it off
and
tell her that i was going to deal with
it in the future or whatever it might be
but this is years of this and in fact
there were times where she would
plan vacations so that she could
rekindle
some of the magic that we had lost you
know um
one time we were in
hawaii to do that it was the first time
i went to hawaii
oh my god oh my god i skip ahead but um
but it got to the point where it's like
what else if i'm not going to change
and i'm not you know and i trust me i
tried um
so it got to the point where i was like
you know we threw out suggestions and
things that um you know this really is
on us for thinking this wasn't going to
be just entirely gay yeah yeah
yeah true i mean
unless they're gonna fight
that's what i'm trying to see i'm going
to skip ahead till i see anything
interesting you know they're being being
very mean toward kalila here we go
that you know none of this was like an
anomaly or
is that the right word or
you know i mean out of nowhere you know
i mean it's a reaction right to my
behavior
um
i've done a lot of
growth in the last six months and end
changes
um i put some hard boundaries down
and um i don't really give a [ __ ]
to be honest with you
what people think
um
i i don't give a [ __ ]
um
and the people that are that are saying
[ __ ] about me and decided [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourself
i mean because you don't know
my this is my personal life yeah but the
only reason your personal life is out
here for us or for anybody because you
all put your personal life you're
putting your personal life out there
look listen this whole which by the way
started by by by brendan and in my
opinion in calan primarily
would you argue that maybe that put all
their [ __ ] out there a little bit more
maybe but then that's the same thing as
then you could also point it back to the
trash tuesday podcast where she aired
and by the way she i never said
brandon's name that's [ __ ] i'm
brendan's not i'm not defending brennan
obviously but they were doing i think oh
his name is bs everybody [ __ ] knew
you knew what you were doing yeah you
they're doing that girl argument we're
on a technicality you're like come on
you know what you [ __ ] you were doing
you know what you were doing so i mean
it kind of feels like you guys put that
stuff out there right
i mean you did
here's a great example
johnny carson was a [ __ ] dude who
let's face it had some issues with women
had a few different wives now
did you ever
ever hear johnny carson ever talk about
his life or what he's going through a
little one-liners once in a while but he
didn't sit there and just [ __ ] tell
you everything that was going on in his
personal life no but i do remember uh
johnny carson denying his black
granddaughter
that's true that's kind of funny though
and this is our life and it's like you
know they're being being very mean
toward kalila
and i've had enough of it you know um
says it could be me and kalila a person
who does a show called trash tuesdays
where all they do is trash other people
on a tuesday
hence the name trash tuesday okay i see
they're innocent they don't do anything
it's unfounded not true so the way so
you you're going to solve this problem
of everybody being mean to kalila
by breaking up with her which everyone
that's being mean to her is just going
to find
reasons to blame her and be meaner to
her that's what's going to happen
um
and um she's a good girl
and i love doberman love her very much
and um i wish people would stop you know
i really do
um
so that's pretty much everything in a
nutshell for me i um
like
i mean i love kalila i love my brother
as well you know um he hurt me
he hurt me
it was painful
um
why is he talking like thomas murphy i
don't know he said
[Music]
i know through time things will heal
and i
but here's the good news
i i'm we're not stopping tiger belly ah
i get a point i get a point
royce nailed that one
um
we're good
we're good
we're not stopping um i'm never gonna
see anybody else in my life
i just know i just i have no interest
will be a priest
so he's breaking up whether he's going
to be with nobody else which means to me
this is her fault yeah she dumped him
and now he's being because she said
something my brother hurt me too
i may be i'm wondering this is my fault
obviously when i'm my [ __ ] you it's not
my fault but my point is it's
we're just going through it live
and i'm i'm trying to see if maybe she
did something if anybody could get a
candle on that let me know i don't know
what he was thinking but um
and um
yeah with all that stuff that he said i
don't i don't know if she he um said uh
her and i building
a business together okay ordeal but
getting like you know
um
a guarantee
you know
so it's not it's not i mean compared to
to all my peers and stuff really and
when i met her you know she kind of
reinvented my thing i made my money
with her
she has her own money
right
all the things that i have
in my life right is a direct result of
meeting her and her her and i building
she helped him get back in tv a lot of
people don't know this yeah i don't
think so she's probably 12.
together
um
other things have
grown out of that like you know my it
rekindled my acting career um you know
he's been in so many things because
you're a household name now
i've done well
i thought he was great in joker
i mean he didn't see his face or
anything but
selling things and whatnot it's been
very good but um
you know without her i don't know where
i'd be you know um
so him saying that she's a goalie on
youtube doing a podcaster digger is not
true she's not oh his brother his
brother says she's a gold digger yeah
she's never asked for anything
um
and so now his brother's going at it
what is happening he um said um things
like he's
she's keeping
you know i mean me from other people or
right or something like bro
his brother
is worried
because
in his eyes he loves him
and she thinks that she's taking
advantage of him
and isolating him from other people this
story we've
everybody has seen this story over and
over again right when you everybody sees
that somebody that's this guy dude
somebody's going out with a succubus
right oh yeah and then they just become
like these withdrawn weirdos right right
but then he starts getting mad at that
that or you know
and um
you know during the pandemic
we didn't see anybody you know you know
i'm tired of people thinking that
i don't make my own decisions you know
kalila told me that peop that i need to
make my own decisions so i'm doing that
dude i'm looking at the reddit right now
is it bad they don't like her
everything that i do i make my own
decisions i'm bobby lee i
do it's hard to find just like a bullet
point because everybody is just taking
up all of the [ __ ] space talking [ __ ]
about her
right
and during the pandemic i was super
[ __ ] scared i didn't know anything
about this virus i didn't leave the
house for a year and a half i didn't
even go to the grocery store for a year
and a half oh my god these la people
really live like that they weren't we're
we're [ __ ] doing
merch and i went during calvin martian i
went to vegas twice
and he's not leaving his room for two
years it became and cornets another one
they haven't still haven't left this
house like dude why are you people so
scared
really just just just really exacerbated
their mental illnesses and you're like
okay i mean i'm going out but i
understand people being being worried to
die right i get i get that yo i don't
want to die and that happens to some
people but it's like
so why so you want to live your life
terror you want to live a long terrified
life instead
and and and i didn't see my brother you
know i mean i didn't see my mom
right i didn't see anybody right um
so the brother's saying hey man you
haven't seen us in two years just this
[ __ ] is not [ __ ] letting you come
see us and bobby's like no it's not that
it said i'm terrified of a superbug
yeah it's the pandemic even though i'm
doing a show every week with a bunch of
people in the studio without my son
correct
and you know
i think that's at the comedy store yeah
oh yeah of course my brother thought
that that was you know i mean me
disappearing or you mean or you know i
mean something was going on you know i
mean that was like you know what i mean
you know i mean no um
i don't know i don't know what he was
thinking but um
and um
yeah with all that stuff that he said i
don't i don't know if you guys even if
people even listening knows but you know
he had texted some random person
his gripes that were absolutely
unfounded and not true no i'm sorry i
would love to hear his brother's side on
this am i the only one that feels like
i kind of unders even even with him
spinning the story right even with him
trying to make it look i still feel like
the brother had a valid problem i think
there was something going on
that that he felt like bro you haven't
been around ever since you started
dating this chick or whatever i think
that that's the issue
and people have taken that and ran with
it online
and it's really hurtful to kalyal it's
hurtful to me
um
and i just wanted to address it so you
know
just
you know
another thing that i want to add is
you know i
was blatantly
flirting with other people and there was
things that she caught me in that were
like you know i mean kind of um
you know
it took her about i did some lying you
know i mean
and there were things that you know none
of this is like rumors that she's
cheated on him in hawaii too yeah we
brought that up before i think yeah to
be honest with you what people think
um
[Music]
i i don't give a [ __ ] all right we got
to uh i have no interest i have no
interest in any of that no i'm just
telling any girl i'm not listening i
will not listen i will not cuddle
i will not cuddle i will not listen and
i don't give a [ __ ]
all right i'm not doing any of it i it's
it's not who i am
so that's that it's this has nothing to
do with bro la people are really [ __ ]
up man you guys are broken like
it's one thing if it was just like one
of them but like
how many of these people have we covered
that have this
weird
broken thing inside of them where they
can't make human connections and it's
about the shoes and knowing joe rogan
and and hey and i got a movie roles it's
it's man it seems really sad to me right
it's a it's a weird place it's a weird
soulless place it like sucks the life
out of you huh
you know i mean anybody else or
my desires or whatever it has to do with
preserving
tiger belly
kalila and i work great together we have
great idea how many months
before
yeah
show links i dropped a a screenshot of a
text conversation from steve lee
okay
like the the gray is steve i don't know
who he's talking about wait steve steve
lee is his brother
yeah
younger brother who's also a comedian
is he funny
um uh it's kind of it's kind of
pixelated but i found out he was a
comedian by googling bobby lee brother
so i guess he's not that great
all right uh so wait the which one's him
the top one or the bottom one the
okay fine
jesus texting some friend
that's what it looks like okay all right
so here's you i'll do the brother and
you could do the friend merch
she [ __ ] some other guy hawaii that
i don't think that's how he's saying his
name's lee
i'm gonna do it the way brennan would do
it
she's [ __ ] okay she's [ __ ] some
other guy in hawaii
hey
uh their relationship is just smoking
mirrors
all right and since they're all in l.a
i'm gonna assume the friends of mexicans
yes yes that's fine so i'm gonna go yo
that's awful i hope it doesn't hurt your
brother fool
oh he in pain
he just got cycled in tucson i think she
she arranged that it was supposed to be
rehab
uh that kills me holmes
he should throw her back to long beach
she's so full of [ __ ] at six playing a
nine
that makes him so ugly sorry i'm shook
fool
so apparently he was in a psych ward in
tucson
yeah when it was supposed to be rehab oh
these people are [ __ ] so broken dude
let me tell you big difference between
hollywood rehab and tucson psych ward
yeah vergie i could probably guess that
i want to just
share it right it's on the same page
[ __ ] arizona desert trash yeah i get
it
there's just [ __ ] no ac in a bunch of
[ __ ] schizos ever even banging
everybody has everybody has a gecko
tattoo or a cactus
you [ __ ] weird desert people or an
asu tattoo as you that's right and you
know a psych ward in tucson everybody's
screaming about aliens and abductions of
course
ideas we're producing another thing
together we're going to do a book you're
i mean and you know um i'm super excited
about you should write a book which is a
list of all the names of all the guys
she [ __ ] in hawaii
again jericho's list
just an unfurled long list number three
armbar
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] it you're right it would
actually be more like
number three theo vaughn
number four brian callan but she lists
him in the order she [ __ ] them so the
names come up more than one time like
like arm bar does on jericho's list
of my business here
um we have a great family um
and uh it seems like it
that's it everything seems great for you
guys that's all i wanted to say
your turn
it's michael yeah you have anything
um
she's struggling yeah i just uh i should
have [ __ ] i should have just [ __ ]
brendan when i had the chance yeah that
would have been so much more money i
kind of feel like i could have i kind of
[ __ ] this up defending you huh
could it just [ __ ] brendan and right now
i'd be in an f-150 and now i might be
able to blow brian callan maybe i'm now
have to go if i would have been on the
sting and the bing and the ping and the
ling and the the ching and the don't
worry sweetheart there's a [ __ ] spot
for you right here
[Laughter]
is there a twitter account named joey
diaz's dry mouth
great i'm sad but i love you and
why that's it
that's it
um
just give me a second yeah
i just don't want to like say it um
this podcast has like
changed my life i never this i have so
much more money now and so many more
podcasts than friends this feels like
a cw show it looks like the set of a cw
show i mean honestly look at it
it looks like the set of a cw show
it feels like the vibe of one you know
you know pacey
if it wasn't for you meeting down to the
creek
i would have never fell in love with you
and then there's and then it's then it's
just insert generic creek yes in town
here
we'll always have that place
we'll always have the summer at that
lake tiger belly pass
tiger belly pass god damn it we'll
always have tiger berry fast
ula people are [ __ ] stuck well you
guys are terrible never thought that i
could ever like dabble in anything
creative you know who can dabble in the
creative things the dabbler himself yes
yes yes
like you know that cool who's the black
ball for the industry because i'm too
progressive i'm too liberal i'm too
liberal you know what the problem is is
this uh this alt-right republican-run
california comedy scene
you're right
mentioned earlier when you were like
what's one thing your younger self would
like never believe yeah is that i would
even be allowed or that i would allow
myself like a creative outlet
you seem angry
i'm just i'm gonna see how this the end
of this clip is um we're fine
i think we're fine
oh yeah i guess that's it they're fine
guys right but i'm okay with that
because the people that do listen to us
are
like-minded and um i can't be anything
else
right that's the thing i'm i this is the
first thing in my life
yeah i try i always try to fit into
these like i'm on a sketch show so i
gotta learn yeah you must live a really
tortured life bobby stop it i'm so sick
of people not being able to [ __ ] put
gas in their car put food on the [ __ ]
table having four have [ __ ] [ __ ]
arrive in their house on time go to a
job that pays them i [ __ ] have milk
cost 60 dollars now because of inflation
and these la comics are whining about
how they don't fit in man into the
greater scheme of things dude i [ __ ]
hate it your therapists are lying to you
all right you're never gonna get better
you wanna know why because the one day
you realize that we all [ __ ] suck and
there's not a jewish doctor that's gonna
fix it you'll feel better okay
god damn it with these people
go easy on bobby man he's he's hurting
is he is he he's a tortured artist is he
hurting